[Musique]
ambiance jazz ambiance groovy ambiance
funky ce soir à la batterie alors c'est
pas mal en guise d'introduction mais moi
je vous propose de passer tout de suite
à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
rock'n'roll le rock'n'roll c'est
justement le thème qu'a choisi leur
gardien et son équipe pour fêter la
musique et pour faire leur fête de la
musique décalée alors pourquoi le choix
de ce thème c'est la question
posez c'est parti
[Musique]
et
open qui répète ici dans nos studios
sont majoritairement des groupes pop
rock longueur a pas qu'à 20%
évidemment ça se ressent sur les
blackhawks or l'on propose ce soir et
âme tu veux tu joues beaucoup de
classiques rock
j'ai un peu pop rock aussi ça les
pensées des générations feront toujours
amant aussi dans nos studios toutes
sortes de génération rock
maintenant très anciens voilà la mode
fait aussi son anniversaire aujourd'hui
autant de styles que d'interprète et
quand on demande aux spectateurs si le
roc leur évoque quelque chose
chacun y va de sa référence hendrix
un exemple plutôt dans les années 60-70
de la musique qui bouge
la musique avec beaucoup d'instruments
la guitare électrique
[Musique]
cdc metallica volbeat les beatles un
plot to rolling stones aussi pour moi
parce que je suis pas une adepte
particulièrement de cette musique c'est
plutôt une époque
les années 70 la grande liberté
les barrières pour fait tomber et tout
ça ouais bon je pense que ça a le mérite
d'être clair en tout cas quel que soit
le style l'origine ou l'interprète
les spectateurs présents samedi soir à
la batterie ont eu l'occasion de s'en
mettre plein les oreilles écoutez
[Musique]
bonjour
et
[Musique]